sonic games aren't going anywhere and  neither are special editions luckily the  sonic mania collector's edition looks  pretty awesome I'm Tony and this is your  speedy GameSpot news update the  highlight of the package is a 12-inch  sonic statue with a base modeled after  the Sega Genesis  you can even flip a switch to hear the  iconic it also contains a Sega cartridge  cast golden ring and metallic card with  a download code for the game that all  comes packaged in a collector's box that  resembles a Sega Genesis game case no  official price was announced but Amazon  lists the collector's edition at 70  bucks  sonic mania is headed to ps4 Xbox one  and PC and spring 2017 and the  collector's edition is available on all  platforms we'll have plenty more  gameplay and trailers before launch day  so keep an eye on gamespot for more and  for all the biggest bluest Sonic news  you're already in the right place  you